[Music]
all right we are now live for the a.m. a
session for February let me get
everything set up here and say hello to
everybody who is on their way into the
session I gotta get my thing up here so
I can actually see the chat since then
these hangouts you can't actually see it
let's see if we've got any questions or
oh yeah whole bunch of questions already
so no further ado let's get started
and take some of these questions so ap
asks does Bataille have the best
interpretation of Nietzsche but a long
time since I've read but I but I
wouldn't say that I would imagine he
would have the best interpretation of
nature but it's kind of a trick question
because it's not as if there is a best
interpretation of Nietzsche the great
thinkers who you see talking about
Nietzsche tend to emphasize the themes
that they find most interesting and
Nietzsche is you know the proverbial
whacks nose right you can bend it in
whatever direction you want to so I
don't really think that there is a best
interpretation of Nietzsche out there
that you could point to let's see what
else we've got here a disciple of rock
are there any philosophers or
theologians that argue for Monas
metaphysics and not the traditional
arguably platonically influenced
metaphysics of traditional Christian
orthodoxy well I mean Christian
orthodoxy is not usually monistic you it
usually tends to be pluralistic right
other things exist besides just the one
substance that would that would be God I
mean Spinoza is a hardcore monist
everything is ultimately
substance and attributes and modes of
that substance so yeah there's plenty of
philosophers out there theologians um I
don't know if there's if there's that
many theologians that that are doing
that so all right so your forests whose
ethics make the most sense to you well I
think a lot of you know I'm an eclectic
when it comes to both philosophy and
when it comes to ethics so there's
there's no single one that makes the
most sense I guess in the earlier days
you could have said that I was you know
along the Aristotelian path and I still
draw on Aristotle and the Aristotelian
tradition considerably but you know I
also like the the play tennis and I like
the Stoics and I like quite a few later
thinkers picking up a number of
different people along the way as well
so you know I I would say on the whole
that I are like virtue ethics the best
but any good virtue ethicist is going to
be trying to incorporate what they can
from advances that come about in in
other traditions like for example you
know any good virtue ethicist is going
to read Conte and engage with contour
read mill and engage with mill or you
know read contemporary ethics of care
and feminist philosophy and engage with
that or you know if there's something
else that's been left out of the picture
they're going to see if it needs to be
addressed in some way that's how people
like Aristotle or later Aquinas or you
know and then the present Alistair
McIntyre that's how they they view
virtue ethics and I think you can say
the Stoics were really doing the same
thing both in the classic sense and in
in the modern you know interpretations
of it as well
um let's see here Daniel Simpson back
how would you characterize Hegel's
conception of freewill can it be thought
of in analytic terms like compatibilism
hard determinism libertarianism etc and
what are your own views on freewill so
yeah I guess you know and you really
think about this that much but I guess
it's mostly analytics who liked that
language and distinction of hard
determinism libertarianism compatibilism
you know the analytic philosophy is
nothing if not obsessed with creating
new terms a new form of scholasticism
and every once in a while they're good
you know so long as you actually know
what the terms mean once they define
them you're gonna be very hard-pressed
to fit Hegel into the categories of
analytic philosophy as a matter of fact
you're going to be hard-pressed to fit
most good people in the history of
philosophy within the confines of both
the method and the terminology that
typically goes with the analytic
philosophy which is why you know most
analytic philosophy of history is just
not very good we're fortunate and that
we've got somebody who is quite good
coming here to Milwaukee this month
there's going to be a conference on
Brandon's thought and he's giving the
Aquinas lecture here at Marquette
University just down the road but he's
an exception to the rule I mean you know
it's very hard to shoehorn Hegel
evidence in many continental thinkers
approaches to things or you know a
virtue ethics dialectical approach right
what's my own views on on freewill I
would say that I'm essentially a
compatibilist but I'm you know I I
almost find it I almost always find it
very boring to figure out is somebody a
determinist a compatibilist a
libertarian and I'm much more interested
in well how do they think the will
actually works and to what degree do we
have some freedom from this causal Nexus
that all of our actions inevitably go
right back into you know so I'm you know
I I would say that a
if you want to if you want to be really
hardcore buddy so it can't be a
compatible it's got to be either a
libertarian or a determinist of some
sort
I don't know compatibilism is the more
interesting area because then you gotta
explain how do these things actually
come together and there's a long
tradition of that you know think about
car nyada's position as represented in
cicero's on fate or you know the Stoics
gyrations to try to have a compatibilist
doctrine that's really much more
deterministic then then the the academic
doctrine was or think about Augustine
and his criticism of you know the
previous thinkers and and you know in
terms of divine foreknowledge and for
you know human freedom and boy he is
carrying on the same thing and then an
some adding to the mix all of those are
you know quite quite interesting I think
that a lot of times people bandy about
these terms like freewill and they don't
really they they only have a very vague
conception of what it would mean or a
very crude conception of what it would
mean
the will is going to be an incredibly
complex phenomenon not something
absolutely simple so we want to I think
treated accordingly we want to have
accounts that are adequately you know
adequately developed you could say so
let's see what the next question is oh
how do you this is from Evan MJ d'amour
how do you think the conversation would
go if Nietzsche met Kierkegaard and both
knew and read the other's works so that
almost was a possibility historically I
mean not for Kierkegaard to read
Nietzsche but rather for Nietzsche to
read Kierkegaard so how did how did that
come apart about while there was this
guy Gord grandes in
[Music]
Denmark who is lecturing on lecturing on
Kierkegaard among other things he
lectured I don't remember everything
else that he dug into him at one point
and he correspondent with Nietzsche and
he recommended that Nietzsche should
read of all things Dostoevsky which
Nietzsche did and enjoyed and then that
Nietzsche should also check out this
Kierkegaard guy but he didn't he didn't
do it as far as we know now how would
things have turned out I mean you could
look at the common themes between them
the focus on the individual the current
age that were in particularly because of
the press and a democratization of
things you know leading to a kind of
leveling you know I think that there's a
lot of things that they have in common
and this is why thinkers in the later
existentialist movement were noting the
the connections between these guys so I
think that's kind of a good good point
right but you know would they have had
some places where they simply couldn't
have gotten along where I don't know
that sort of that's a really interesting
question I think somebody who who
understands the biography of both of
them and their own psychology is better
and is less interested in the ideas as
such would be a better person to answer
that so all right let's see what we've
got here more more questions that just
jumped a little bit here we go James oh
corn to what extent do you think that
some kind of teleology as a feature of
the world and how does this fit into
your virtue ethics well I mean I think
that there's a lot of things that are
teleological in the world but they may
not have there's a couple things say
there there's a lot of things there that
are clearly teleological there there's
some sort of function some sort of end
some sort of purpose but it may not be
exactly the
one that we think it is when it comes to
man-made artifacts of course obviously
there's things that are teleological you
know this this cup is is designed to
hold the coffee that clearly has you
know been dripping on it because I
haven't washed it from from this morning
but I'm drinking the coffee right the
cup has achieved its purpose the the
coffee is there and it was brewed and
mixed with milk because I like the taste
of that and and I enjoy the the
effective of the caffeine you know we
can take an object after object what
about other things like you know animals
or plants you know they they I think
they do have their own teleology I don't
think it's you know simply to serve man
or something like that and I think when
we come to human beings it gets way way
more complicated so there's that and I
don't see any reason why a thing can't
have more than one end or you know start
taking on additional ends I think that
the old fashioned way of dealing with
teleology in a very kind of cookie
cutter way is probably you know a bad
idea and it's part of what gave
teleology a bad name and rightly so now
how does it fit in with virtue ethics so
I was just talking about this with my
students yesterday and my Marquette not
yesterday two days ago in my Marquette
foundations of philosophy class we were
we were reading Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics books three and four and talking
about specific virtues and I asked them
before we went into it so why do you
need these traits of character and of
course they gave me the usual answer as
well it makes life easier dealing with
other people you stay out of trouble
people will like you and all that I said
well I mean is that all there is to this
stuff or you know to some of these
things possess their value because they
actually help you live a good life a
life that you want to live do they help
you develop as a person and of course
you know they're in a difficult
situation because they they're
encountering this
you know in any sustained way for the
first time except for the kids who who
may had a little smattering of this in
Catholic High School where it was
probably badly taught quite frankly and
it was just you know sort of here's
here's the the lines you know here's the
four cardinal virtues here's the three
theological virtues memorize these for
the test and there really wasn't a lot
of attentiveness to the sort of back and
forth between well you start to develop
the virtue a bit and and you know
recognize where you're vicious and start
to you know want to move away from that
and and you change your habits a little
bit and you make better choices for you
know some some instances and now you
actually start to see it's like you see
the horizon moving a little bit further
and you start to have a better
understanding of why the virtues are
important I don't think they're choose R
or the teleology of human life is
something that one can grasp and in one
fell swoop you know it's it's a
composite picture that we put together
over time I mean there may be some
people who grasp it intuitively but I'm
sure not one of them and I don't know
too many other people who who I think
would be alright chip though outside
McIntyre's criticism of human rights
there are no such rights belief in them
is at one with belief in witches and
unicorns what text would you recommend
as a counterpoint well two to one
MacIntyre thing you probably want to dig
around and more MacIntyre
you know he's rejecting a sort of
establishment view of human rights that
says people just have them and this is
what the discourse is and you know quite
frankly the whole discourse of human
rights winds up being a bit of a mess
when somebody doesn't feel like honoring
it you know I mean think about how
mainland China
you know just recently there's been I
forget exactly where where it was but it
was in one of the you know big party
gatherings they were talking about how
the whole discourse of human rights
really doesn't understand Chinese
community and and I mean this is a
massive repercussions for anybody who's
a minority in China or the Han majority
as well and so I think there's something
to that if we want things like human
rights to be recognized there'd better
be some basis better than I just feel
that they're there or the UN declared
them to be the case you know X number of
years ago we need something that we can
we can appeal to other people and the
moral traditions that they operate
within
Mason MacIntyre thoughts on planting uh
interesting sometimes not somebody who I
really read much of because I'm not into
analytic philosophy of religion his
advice his advice to Christian
philosophers is something that I checked
out because you know when I was doing
all that work on the Christian
philosophy debate totally uninformed by
any of the wider literature beyond the
analytics fear or the you know the Dutch
Reformed tradition and so you know it
it's okay for people who you know hadn't
read much but it's it missed so many
opportunities and you know I've seen him
speak he's an interesting guy
she had he's got some interesting ideas
but there's plenty of other people could
spend their time on him all right
Poehler chimes any advice for people
seeking a closer relationship to the
divine well that's a tough one I mean
all the great spiritual you know
traditions say that you have to do a lot
of practice and so you know whatever
whatever it's gonna however you're going
to conceive of it or what are you going
to be doing you probably need to be
doing some prayer or meditation or some
sort of practice and there's better be
some ethical component to it as well and
then you know what else do they do lots
of reading and meditating on on texts
and thinking things through so I would
say that's that's
important I mean when I want to try to
deepen my connection to the divine the
text that I'm typically going to are you
know people like Rainer Maria Rilke and
st. Anselm of Canterbury and you know
John Cassian and and you know G K
Chesterton Iris Murdoch people like that
that probably isn't gonna work for
everybody else right all right Maxim war
zosky
question about Nietzsche's comments on
the Stoics is there any reason for the
confusion over the Greek word for nature
it seems odd nature being kind of a
Greek expert it wasn't kind of a Greek
expert he was a philologist he wasn't an
expert in ancient languages it's not a
question of getting the terminology
wrong he distorts stomach philosophy
because it doesn't fit into his point of
view you can say the same thing about
hegel hegel knew his Greek Hegel also
gets the Stoics wrong in interesting
ways and you know Nietzsche is is going
after the Stoics the way Nietzsche it
goes after a lot of people points that
that certainly do seem vulnerable but
but also oftentimes not being entirely
fair I mean to expect Nietzsche to be
fair is kind of kick sonic though isn't
it right I mean think about the rest of
his his philosophical stance so you know
there you go Kyle what does it mean to
be a virtue ethicist I suppose that
depends probably on what sort of brand
or tradition of virtue ethics that
you're looking at I mean I would say
that it's going to if you're gonna
really take it seriously it's got to be
applied to your actual life and you
probably want to even seek out a
community of other people who are trying
to do that and you know that cuts down
on your opportunities significantly you
know because there aren't that many
people out there there's funny people
who use the word virtue but have no idea
what what virtue
really means you know and you don't want
to get in with them many of them are you
know part of our intelligence and our
you know academic types too but you know
it wouldn't it would mean to like decide
that you I mean let's say we take
Aristotelian virtue ethics you'd need to
read some Aristotle and not necessarily
accept everything that he says obviously
you're gonna throw some of it away
and some of it you're gonna say well I
need to use Aristotle against Aristotle
here which by the way there's a word for
that
deconstruction you know do you actually
look at what what Derrida I was doing
that sort of reading has been around for
a very very very long time
you know it's not something new or
postmodern as so many people like to
pretend but yeah you would you would
start you know thinking your life
through Aristotle and and you would say
okay Aristotle tells us in the
Nicomachean ethics that he's gonna give
us the outlines then it's up to us to
fill in the gaps
you'd have to exercise your mind and
think about am I actually being generous
or am I just trying to appear generous
am i moving away from my bad temper or
my intemperance or things like that all
right
Jermel what are my thoughts on either
and you know I wasn't something I've
talked about quite quite a bit before I
think she's a you know a third-rate
philosopher but she's a third-rate
philosopher I think when it comes to the
history of philosophy she's terrible but
so many others are as well I mean don't
read Will Durant or Bertrand Russell for
faithful history of philosophy don't
really handle for that matter either
because it's all going into Hegel's
hopper and he's giving you what he
thinks the history of philosophy is
really about and you know I think that
you know she's often deciding to
approach things in a rather tendentious
way but you know she did her thought
does deserve to be studied just as much
as as anybody else's I don't think we
should look sanguine Li at the academic
boycott on even mentioning her
she gets a place at the same table as
everybody else and then you know you can
just judge her on on her merits then and
when I do that you know I don't find her
particularly great know that I sell you
believe Jesus is God well I'm a
Christian so what do you think
la cipher is a nice personal non
philosophical question how's your day
well I've been sick lately and really
rundown I imagine after I finished with
this I'll probably need a nap or
something you know teaching like my
classes just took everything out of me I
haven't been able to shoot any video
this entire week because I've been too
too worn out I haven't worked out either
but the day's been okay I got some
quizzes created for my classes online
I've been working on a workshop that I'm
going to be delivering on Monday about
how to actually have a career in
philosophy with a philosophy degree
outside of academic philosophy for
philosophy majors at a local school
so I like that and yeah hopefully I'm
gonna get a lot of other work done
before I lose steam because I'm you know
kind of anxious about the amount of work
that I have to get done teaching five
classes this semester that is a lot and
I'm also in the process of course design
taking a face-to-face business ethics
class putting it online for summer I
have to put class proposals together for
other summer classes and I'm supposed to
be doing some professional development
stuff her MATC that I haven't haven't
gotten to yet either
so alright but thanks for asking
very nice names system eight I'm sure
I'm mispronouncing that I heard you say
to talk you didn't like vogner what
about just the music preludes etc I mean
I'm just I'm not a fan of vogner I'm
actually not a fan of
a lot of classical you know but I don't
you know I don't have to be because you
know I'm not somebody who has to have
appreciation of things I like Bach you
know I like a lot of that baroque stuff
not really big on Beethoven or Mozart or
you know that that whole tradition I
know I like lists from what I've heard I
like barely oats and you know I like
quite a few more contemporary things
like Stravinsky and Prokofiev is
probably my favorite well you know it's
not as if I've studied it enough to
actually know why I feel okay I do
I was just found vogner a little bit too
much for me
you know all right bill sois soul
sneakin siddur Kierkegaard's edifying
works to be philosophically interesting
so it works of love with purity of heart
have you considered doing any videos on
this part of authorship
yeah I think they're really really
interesting because you know he talks
about some some great stuff there and he
does so in a funny way I'll give you an
example from works of love right so he
he's he's talking about this injunction
to love thy neighbor as thyself
and he says Christianity he's sort of
prefiguring Chesterton here right
Christianity is being very realistic
people you know saying that it's it's
you know requiring this this
pie-in-the-sky
attitude he says no no no Christianity
is being completely realistic you can't
really love the other more than yourself
that's what the poet's think that's what
all the Romantic people think but that's
all bs
you know if you can just love the
neighbor as you love your own miserable
screwed-up self which is way more than
you actually should then you're gonna be
doing a great job and Christianity only
demands that you get that far because
because that's already tough enough I
mean that's brilliant isn't it it's such
a such a wonderful insight I'm actually
considering using
to talk about things in in one of my
ethics classes when we talk about the
egoism versus altruism thing you know
again you who do we use for the egoism
we use Rand and then maybe some sterner
or some other things as well and you
know the the egoist sort of projects
onto people oh you know the altruist is
saying you have to you have to treat
yourself like crap and and you know
treat everybody else great subordinate
yourself to something else and I mean I
guess some altruists are like that
Kierkegaard is not like that he's like
listen you already do love yourself you
know even though you probably don't have
a right to love yourself wait yeah so
Christianity wants you to treat your
other people like that that's again
brilliant so have I considered doing any
videos yeah yeah but I am I'm you know
trying to get a lot of stuff done for my
classes this semester a lot of core
concept videos so it's gonna be a long
time before I get to anything that's not
directly for my classes I mean actually
I just looking at my desktop today I'm
hoping since I'm now feeling a bit
better then I can finish up the James
Rachel's stuff because I did some some
things on his discussion of cultural
relativism and then I've got three short
videos they need to create on Lawrence
Kohlberg I got some a gar emotivism
stuff some R and stuff I'm not going to
do all of them today obviously but
that's that's the stuff I got to get
done first and then I got a you know
start shooting some Augustine for for
your choice of the will and some and
some and stuff like that so I'm not
gonna get to that the character you
garden Nicola do we now live in Neil ISM
or do we just after death of God instead
of changing values we kept the old ones
from Christianity why not both I mean if
we're adopting a Nietzschean perspective
or some sort of broader perspective
indebted to it if we're keeping the old
values that we've got from Christianity
and then transforming them in the
process there's no reason why that can't
be nihilistic I mean Nietzsche thinks
that the scientists
or you know we would we would say a
secularist way of looking at things
since the Enlightenment that that takes
the priests out of the picture and puts
the man of science in his place he says
that's just as superstitious and you
know as anything that the Christians
ever did that's just as subject to
foundering and to kneel ISM as you know
what the church did so Kyle I've been
reading some of Seneca stuff on anger
from a very compelling do you think
there's any case for anger what about
when you're angry at yourself for being
angry well that's an interesting one so
John Cassian who's another hardliner
like the Stoics you know anger is never
good the one exception he makes is
getting angry at your own self for your
anger or your other vices so I you know
I'm not a this is one place where I
don't follow the Stoics strictly
although I do draw upon them very
heavily because they've got some great
techniques and and insights about anger
but I I don't I don't follow them
strictly on the side I'm more
Aristotelian you can say or you know the
Epicureans also thought there was a
thing natural anger lactantius thought
there's a good case for anger as well
brass kava krilova do you have a
religion I do
Molly boy what are your thoughts on
arguments for antinatalism I haven't
read any arguments for antinatalism
because it's not really an area that I
pay much attention to I've I've heard
people you know talk about antinatalism
but I haven't looked at any arguments
closely so not much to say awful
philosophy what philosophers are good if
one wants to get into aesthetics I know
Schopenhauer i stuff about orchestration
is he someone you'd recommend for
someone into classical composition well
you're asking sort of a couple different
things I mean aesthetics is way wider
than music right so if you're interested
in muse
I mean you'd start with looking at the
it's kind of crude stuff but there's
discussions of music and the modes and
Plato and Aristotle and in the Republic
and then in politics right and then
Aristotle had a student aristocracy
knows who wrote a lot of works but we
only have one of his on on harmony I
think it is check him out and there's
others in the ancient and medieval
period who have things to say about
about music as well so I would check
that stuff out if you're if it's really
about music I mean need to know some
interesting things to say about music
and his works as well all right ship
what historical influence did Leibniz
Theodoric have do you mean theodicy
because I don't know anything about
Theodoric was a a guy back in boethius's
time right I remember right
his theodicy what influence that I have
probably have more influence in people
making fun of it I mean Voltaire
famously makes fun of it in Candide but
I think a lot of other people didn't
really buy the argument either that this
is the best of all possible worlds
meaning that this is the best that God
could could make and God chose the best
made of clays niall ISM a boundary to
its own niall ism or that niall ism
itself is the limits of whatever
nothingness it stands for that's that's
kind of a hard one to wrap your head
around
niall ISM is the limits or whatever
nothingness there's a really a limit to
nothing that's right except maybe being
neol ism is not a thing it's a whole
sort of standpoint and historical
movement and it's not something that
stays still and you can pin down to a
board is Neel ism a boundary to its own
Neel ISM are you asking if neol ism is
in some way soft for feuding or or what
I'm not quite sure how to answer that
memento mori could I recommend a book
that philosophically examines the
historical development of how we
conceive power I mean we're so is good
on on that sort of thing I mean good in
the sense that he brings up interesting
ideas not good in the sense that he
probably gets everything across power is
such right
I mean Hobbes has some great discussions
in there who else
I mean Machiavelli of course but you
know you want to read the discourses on
Livy as well as the prince in that case
I mean it really depends on what we're
talking about is power I mean there's
all this stuff going forward into the
present you know with people like
Foucault who focused heavily on on power
as well although his treatments are
often very they're very you know
systematic for what they focus on but
then they leave so much out so they're
deceptively systematic yeah it's a good
question all right let me take this one
that just popped up my name is Amara I'm
a mature student in my first year of a
psychology degree I'm in a philosophy
course reading Kant groundwork and
mirror and Gras religion religion within
the limits of mere reason and my
professor is terrible unprepared and
aloof any tips or advice well that sucks
and I'm sorry that you're stuck in that
situation there are so many philosophers
who don't have any business in the
classroom teaching that unfortunately
have teaching posts so it's clear you're
probably not going to get any help from
your professor so there is some good
news especially when it comes to cut my
students the trouble that they have with
Conte usually comes in in two different
forms one is the terminology itself
figuring out what the hell is this guy
talking
all right and so what is this op your
apple tree or a synthetic analytic you
know he uses all the out these other
terms that we're often familiar with but
they have sort of a technical use like
inclination you know what is an
inclination or the Faculty of desire you
know so that you can kind of you know
once you've actually cracked the code
you can figure out what the hell he's
talking about and the good news is he's
using the same code in the religion with
within the limits of mere reason as he
is in the groundwork because they're all
part of one big moral project right
the other thing that throws students is
they're like wait once I figure out what
he's saying they're like wait a second
does he actually mean this morality has
nothing to do with happiness as a matter
of fact if we're making ourselves happy
were being immoral and the answer is
yeah yeah he actually does believe that
stuff and so once once you get past that
hump you know another thing to keep in
mind when you're reading a philosopher
it's not it's not about whether you
agree with him or her at first
that may come later like if you're
writing a critical essay or you need to
articulate whether you agree or disagree
it's whether you understand their
physician and how well you understand
their position that provides you with
the basis then to be able to say I think
they're wrong or I think they're right
but like I said I sympathize with you I
had some some pretty terrible teachers
myself in my own career and you know
sometimes that made the difference
between wanting to study somebody and
not wanting to study somebody so the
other thing to do too is realize and you
probably already have done this that the
discipline and the thinkers are
independent of the the jerk or jackass
who happens to be teaching it at any
given time right
say Valley is there any difference
between pre predicative and
pre-conceptual in terms of who Cyril and
Merrill upon team I don't know it's been
a long time since I've read Merrill
Aponte's phenomenology of perception and
I've been digging around in some host
role recently as I as a teacher this was
not somebody I read for fun they got to
tell you but I imagine so
I mean pregnant predicative has to do
the language I pre-conceptual has to do
with thought formation Ava Ava how'd it
go about learning to write philosophical
essays what philosopher's do you like
the most regarding literary quality I
don't have a favorite as far as literary
quality there are some philosophers who
definitely not good writers Hegel is one
of them you know Nietzsche is a good
writer
Schopenhauer is a great writer William
James I like you know Maurice blown down
the guy I wrote my dissertation on not a
great writer
Cicero's great writer but you know it's
kind of an acquired style he writes
these massive you know paragraph long
sentences but how do you go about
learning to write philosophical essays
well there is no there's no recipe for
that but I would say that again this
this notion of first you have to
understand the person that you're
studying then you can go on to
articulate their position then you can
go on to say whether you think they've
got things right or got things wrong
that's important and you know philosophy
tends to stress although they often give
more lip service than actually
exhibiting this they say stress clarity
and exposition that that's good it's
sort of like Occam's razor though
Occam's razor does not say the simplest
explanation is the best as a matter of
fact that's a stupid misinterpretation
of Occam's razor and it's caused so much
trouble Aachen Arkham says we shouldn't
multiply entities beyond necessity that
means that if we need 30 entities to
explain something that it should be the
complicated we shouldn't reduce it to 26
or 2/3 because it makes us feel cool to
have you know done that but we you
shouldn't have like 86 to explain it
either and you can say the same thing
with clarity some things are really easy
to make clear you know if you poke
yourself with this thumbtack you know
you're probably gonna bleed I'm not
going to actually do it I'm just
demonstrating right and you know to
explain why that's the case while
there's blood in this finger and I
puncture it very clear right explaining
exactly how the circulatory system works
more complicated right and so it's gonna
it's gonna not be quite as clear unless
you you work it out in in relation to
its complexity so it's the same way with
philosophical ideas if you've got
complicated philosophical ideas or
there's a lot of different ideas you
know connected together then the essay
has to be rather complicated that's
that's really all the advice that I can
give you I think Kyle is there a
crossover between deism and theism is it
possible there can be a remote God who
also has the capacity to intervene at
certain points well I don't know that
that has to be a crossover between days
and theism that could be more pantheism
you know I mean think about a lot of
religions where you have the doers right
the divine doers that are getting things
done at the level that people might
actually interact with them and then
you've got some sort of like divine
principle above them that maybe created
all of them and you know I mean you
could think about this in terms of the
the if a religions you know
traditionally rubra religion with Ola
rune ruler heaven and then all the
deputy races that are interacted with
and prayed to tokens
count of creation with elevate our as
the the grand creator and creating all
of these I forget what he calls them but
you know essentially angels right but
they're they're viewed as gods also
would be along the same lines as well so
you know that takes us a little bit of
far from from deism with deism you just
have a guy who sets things up and that
never does anything I don't even know
that the deism would need any sort of
intermediaries either all right Thomas
Shelby why does everyone hate Iran what
is wrong with objectives Wow I mean
that's a non-starter
not everybody does hey diner and a lot
of people do some people do for good
reasons some people do for bad reasons
bad reasons would be never having read
her just having heard that she's a
terrible person and you know responsible
for why you know Republicans are so
stingy and stuff like that those are bad
reasons good reasons are her her
readings of philosophy as historians are
just crap and she's told all sorts of
other people who bought into that just
as gullibly as the people who don't like
Andrea and and gullibly bought into a
narrative you know I run into these
people who are like oh I love Aristotle
so much because Iran told me Aristotle
is good and you're like you don't know
anything about Aristotle Aristotle would
himself not have had anything to do with
Iran he would have considered her
off-base on a whole bunch of different
things so you know what's wrong with
objectivism a whole bunch of different
things I mean it's it's got a rather
crude approach to moral theories in
general if you follow it you're probably
I mean they've got this ideal of being a
traitor I've met very few Randy ins who
are actually decent human beings then
again I know a lot of other people who
are awful human beings who follow other
things too right
so yeah I know a few of Rand Ian's who
are actually decent human beings but
many of them have qualms about their
their fellow Randy uns so all right this
is from Giovanna
what do you think about the use of
dialog as in Plato and others for
conveying philosophical ideas in Texas
today that's a great question so I think
dialogues are excellent and there are
way more of them than we typically
realize in philosophy you know most
people know about Plato and then they
know about you know Berkeley I wrote
those dialogues and then Hume had the
dialogues on natural religion and that's
about all they they really know and
that's all it's about all that's really
taught Aristotle is supposed to have
written dialogues none of which we
possess and they're supposed to have
been as good as Plato's dialogues
Xenophon also wrote some cool dialogues
too
Cicero's works some of them are
dialogues
now they tend to be more like I'm gonna
talk for a long time about you he'll
join in here but someone Plato's
dialogues are like that and it was a a
common way of doing things in the
medieval period - especially the early
medieval period I mean look at Augustine
right look at boethius's consolation of
philosophy look at st. Anselm's
excellent dialogues as well and then it
continues on into the modern period
there are quite a few dialogues we just
don't generally read them and teach them
unfortunately and it goes on to the to
the present there are still people
writing philosophical dialogue so as a
matter of fact you know if I had the
time you know I I would love to someday
be able to have the luxury of doing like
philosophical workshops where I would
have people write dialogues and then
we'd critique them and say what are the
ideas you're getting across here that
would think that would be amazing
unfortunately you can't do that in the
kind of classes that that I teach for
academic institutions so all right Kyle
are there any artists or art movements
from the modern era that appealed to you
yeah I suppose there are but I don't
actually know all the words for them so
you know I go into
diems and I look around and I say I like
this I don't like this but I I don't I
you know that's actually something I
should find the time to learn more about
Kyle also asks do you think stoicism and
existentialism complete each other in a
certain respect yeah I think they can be
combined you gotta ask whenever somebody
says existentialism who's existentialism
do you mean do you mean Kierkegaard you
mean Nietzsche do you mean chest off do
you mean Camus and I know some people
who we should he's not an existentialist
he's an existentialist he's part of the
existentialist thing there's there's a
whole argument that can be made they're
simply saying I'm not an existentialist
doesn't make you not an existentialist
cause if that was the case Marcel
Heidegger wouldn't be existentialist
either and in each of them and de
Beauvoir right each of them brings a
different thing to the table so can you
combine them yeah and you know I in in
my workshop that I did recently at stoic
on I actually brought in some Ryoka in
talking about personal relationships and
somebody said actually that was the most
useful part of the workshops for me was
the Ryoka did not all the stoic stuff so
yeah you can you can use them to to
produce a greater synthesis dun dun ja I
want to say a quick thank you for your
lessons on YouTube I'm a first year
philosophy student your videos helped me
a lot what are your thoughts on
Heraclitus versus Parmenides well I'm
glad the videos helped Heraclitus versus
Parmenides I wish we had more of their
writings that would be really nice
and with Heraclitus there's really not
enough to go on to say much with
Parmenides what we have is quite
interesting but slow rudimentary that
I'm not sure we can do much with it
[Music]
let's see ray aka me can you point me
towards good pieces that have to do with
Payne uh where did that go to do darn it
I just lost the the thread for a second
let me scroll back up here I right now
just jumped again so many people
weighing in that's that's that's the
problem here right pain ah the origin of
pain which philosopher comes to mind
when you think of pain I mean a lot of
them talk about Plato Aristotle the
Stoics the Epicureans there's a long
long history of talking about pain as
runs through religious and literary
texts as well so there's no one thing to
point you towards alright Giovanna has
another question do you think the fact
issah T of Ayn Rand's emotional baggage
clouded her ability to give a fair
assessment to leftist economic thought
yeah I think that probably played a role
in it I mean I I'm not somebody who
likes to reduce things to biography but
I mean growing up in the budding Soviet
Union I think can be kind of uh I can be
kind of problematic right so yeah I mean
we'll put it to this way she she has
some good criticisms of some people on
the left and some people in the center
and also some people on the right as
well is everything the way that she says
it is not even half and and it's you
know the problem is is that the people
who buy into her stuff they're usually
like movement people she had all the
answers and I think it's just as
dangerous to do that with her as it is
to do that with with other people as
well
do I have any takes or Texan ethical
responses to internal anger and
aggression if someone was aggressive to
me I respond non-violently but feel as
if I should meet out harm I tend to
dwell okay yeah that's that's a that's a
real problem and it sucks and it hurts
when you do that right I mean the Stoics
have a lot of great stuff to say about
anger like I said and you know I've got
some videos on that specifically except
done I've done workshops on that I think
Aristotle is another really great source
for understanding Aang or you have to
kind of piece together the things that
he has to say
and then there's a lot of other other
you know great thinkers out there I
would actually also take a look at
Nietzsche and his discussion of
resentiment and I would look at mocks
Schaller
that's SCH e le are his reinterpretation
of Nietzsche's conception of a result a
month that might be helpful for you so I
would I would take a look at those and
I've got videos on Aristotle in anger
I've given talks on him quite a bit so
you might find those those helpful all
right let's see what else we got here
moon child do have any recommendations
for any books for a beginner in Greek
literature yes with easier stuff okay
start out with like well you know they
started also out on Lucian right the
true history that's a good place to
start
it's nice and short you feel like you're
making progress you learn a lot of words
along the way don't start with Plato
don't and definitely don't try to start
with Homer because you need to hold the
for dictionary all right people
oh you got to start at the beginning
with Homer no no no you first learn
antic Greek and then you know you can
like go down into Koine and read some
Aristotle who's already kind of quaint a
and Epictetus and and you know Plutarch
and people like that a Plutarch's very
attic though but and then you know you
can you can go back and learn how to
read Homeric
that can be good tjf have you ever read
on riebeck songs two sources of morality
and religion or pure ADO's philosophies
and way of life so what do you think
about them they're both great works yeah
I read Barracks own back is an
undergraduate and I thought it was quite
interesting you know I like his his
discussion about these sort of going
further and further out circles and two
different kinds of morality I think
that's a decent idea to work with pure
odd no I think is a you know good
scholar and he's he was a guy who was in
the right place at the right time with
the right word for a lot of people to
think that he like invented something
that hundreds of other people were
talking about at the time you know
philosophies a way of life I mean that
is such a commonplace of 20th century
French philosophy and I don't mean
continental philosophy I mean sort of
the the wide swath of French philosophy
the whole existentialist movement was
oriented around that but you know how
does a good scholar so you're not gonna
hurt yourself reading them just don't
think that this notion of spiritual
practices or philosophy as a way of life
is somehow you know this absolutely
original idea Gabrielle how does extreme
cold feel like I try to avoid as much as
possible
it sucks I to be hot rather than cold
and here in Wisconsin where I grew up
and were you know we're living now it's
not as cold as it used to be used I
remember in the 70s when I was a child
being cold and winter all the time being
cold in school being cold on the bus
being cold in the car being cold at home
it was just you know that's the way it
was and you know i-i've gotten frost bit
at different times in my life that
that's no fun either unfortunately I
haven't lost any extremities you know
when I was in the army it was really
terrible they put us out there and we'd
freeze
alright let me take another one from
Jovana do you have any thoughts or
comments regarding Abelard intention
allistic ethic specifically in relation
to the Sermon on the Mount yeah I mean
you know Abelard is one of the people
who is not unique in this right and some
also says that it's really the intention
that is the the thing that matters the
most although with Ann sonders there's
also you know all these other factors as
there isn't like say Thomas Aquinas too
later on how did how does it connect
with the Sermon on the Mount well you
know if you think about what's going on
the Sermon on the Mount by itself is
tough stuff tough to actually not just
wrap your head around that what the hell
would this mean but to practice and and
so there's this this transformation and
this is part of what Abelard is picking
up on moving away from just you could
call it external or action-oriented
compliance with the moral norms
enunciated in the law and a focus on how
what your mindset is you know there's
and there's lots of people who are like
listen I didn't do anything wrong I you
know I'm a good guy I didn't break any
any rules or anything like that and you
can say yeah but you wanted to and
you're kind of breaking the rules in
your head right now and you know you
think about the two big things in the
Sermon on the Mount one has to do with
adultery and the the desire for somebody
you know you're sleeping with somebody
already in your mind right you're
committing adultery in your heart and
then the other one has to do with anger
you know the law says you shall not kill
but I say to you if you get angry with
your brother
you'll be liable to the judgment I'm
gonna like ratchets it up you know if
you call your brother a fool right now
there's an action involved yeah that's
that's that's that's a great stuff and
that's very important you know you could
say that
this is one of these central aspects of
ethics that people often want to
downplay and get away from and you
always gotta ask him why do you want to
get away from taking in you know
intention or motive or disposition why
do you want to get away from talking
about that and it's usually because
they're not really happy with their own
intentions and motives right are those
of the people that they like alright
this is Patrick
when was classical Greek spoken well so
it's a good question so there were a
bunch of different dialects right what
we think of as classical Greek is really
the dialect that was associated with
Athens because it was the cultural
powerhouse and you could say that what
you would learn in a classical Greek
class would be like you know fifth
century down into like the third century
BC and then you start to get into you
start to move into this other thing that
eventually gets called Koine which a lot
of people say is just simplified but
it's not actually just simplified
there's like more vocabulary that gets
added to it as Greek becomes a lingua
franca across a much larger area and you
know it was used for for quite a long
time I mean by the time that you're into
like the Byzantine Empire it's it's you
know it's changed considerably it's
definitely not the same thing as modern
demotic Greek right all right Bruno del
mola and ultimately can't one say that
philosophy boils down to personal
opinion perspective or other subjective
matters like temperament one can say
whatever one wants right doesn't make it
actually true you would think that you'd
have to actually make a case for that
rather than just say that's the way it
is you know and I don't I mean I don't
buy it I think that for for quite a few
people who are like you know
maybe not even second right but like
lower on down philosophers it's probably
like that right that's where we can say
well your your biography is really
determining your principles isn't it but
I don't think that's the case for
important philosophers they're not
really reducible to their own time they
they they add something new they they
consider it you know as well they they
tell us quite often and what we have of
them about what they think about their
own time and about their temperament I
was actually just just preparing a test
question earlier today about a guy named
stilt Bo Megerian philosopher who Cicero
was saying everybody in ancient times
you know praised because he had a
temperament if you really liked drinking
drinking wine and chasing women yeah
very strong desires for those but he
didn't do it and people praised him for
having these precisely because he didn't
follow these desires and temperament we
can change our temperament so alright
Sean what can someone teach a philosophy
class at high school yeah as a matter of
fact that is a kind of cottage industry
for a lot of people who get their
philosophy PhDs and can't find a job
they go on teaching a Catholic high
school or a Christian high school or a
very you know well-funded
public high school sometimes it happens
overseas where they actually have
philosophy as part of the curriculum but
then it there's all sorts of other
headaches with getting certified there
as well TD LMX what do I make of the
so-called Anthropocene you can treat the
question either in terms of the thing in
itself or if you think there's a thing
in itself or the discourse or both yeah
I mean I think we are in a new era and
we have been for a while where we as the
dominant creature mastering you know in
our own little way because we're really
just you know on this tiny little crust
of the earth much of what's what's going
on in the planet
I think we are arguably in an
anthropocentric of mass extinctions we
have definitely affected the landscape
and we do seem to be affecting weather
patterns and stuff like that and I think
we have to you know we have to be
prudent about it I think I think the
fact that it's become so politicized in
large part because you know we have this
this political system that's permeable
to corruption by all these these
corporations you know I think it's
unfortunate that we we got ourselves
boxed into this thing we're
conservatives like don't they they want
to disbelieve that any anything is ever
happening other than you know six cycles
or things like that no human things have
done anything and if they have and
they've made it better you know and then
we've got you know a lot of liberals who
are you know quite vocal about it and
sometimes kind of strident and then
we've got you know all these other
people vast consensus who are like wow
we got to take care of this world it's
unfortunate that we're stuck in the
political impasse that we are because if
we don't get our act together we
probably will screw things up way more
than they are and that would be a real
shame for us to destroy the possibility
of human life but that's a possibility
Heidegger you know would be easily if he
were around he'd be identifying that
even though he was on the right right
because he's a thinker Travis
thanks do you have any opinions on
philosophy and the writing of Cormac
McCarthy if you haven't read in Moby
Dick I haven't read Cormac McCarthy
Melville
yeah Melville you know knew quite a bit
of philosophy it's been a long time
since I've taken a look at Moby Dick
I did you know read other stuff by
Hawthorne more recently and he's in his
quite it quite an interesting person but
I don't have a lot of opinions as such
anything that's like considered so I
don't know what to tell you about that
other than
you know it's funny when moby-dick came
out apparently got panned people are
like way too long too much too many
digressions on things now of course we
like prescribe it to high school
students as this is really great
literature you know but at the time
people thought there was probably too
much philosophy that's you know that's
one way to ruin your book right have too
much philosophy in it when when you've
got an audience that's not primed for
lots and lots of philosophy like if
you're not a bore Haise already you know
publishing stuff with philosophy that
then you're gonna have a rougher time
all right let's see what else do we have
Pascal all right this is from the number
5 5 5 3 to 7 is Paschal doing a
primitive sort of dialectic in the
Ponce's with his interest in contraries
opposites etc I wouldn't call it a
primitive form of dialectic I'd I'd say
his work is very dialectical and he does
think that you have to you know you have
to look at he's dialectical in the
traditional sense you have to look at
the things that are available and see
from the ideas that you have because you
don't have to reinvent everything what's
what's crap in them and what's what's
good in them and then try to synthesize
it into something more complex and more
adequate I think that's what he's doing
a lot of the time in the nopales A's
Martinez what what is the best book for
an introduction to Hegel greetings from
Spain so I mean if you're asking about
like commentaries on Hegel or you know
Hegel made easy or something like that
you're always going to get somebody
else's take on Hegel I would say though
if you're gonna read Hegel don't try to
read the phenomenology straight off by
itself that's what a lot of people do
because they've all heard that how
important the phenomenology is I would
actually read Hegel's lectures on to two
sets of lectures lectures on the history
of philosophy and lectures on the
philosophy of history because those are
these
introductions they're more readable to
what he's what he's doing and and like I
said earlier I mean don't expect to get
us perfectly accurate history of
philosophy from Hegel alright he's
definitely got his takes on things some
of which were you know kinda problematic
in that they set research back a long
time and we think about his views on the
Stoics but they're always interesting
and you can you can learn a lot from
from that but you know about what his
basic approach is alright yeah so NOS XD
how should we view the progression of
spirit and Hegel this uncertainty refer
to a particular time in the history
humanity or a mode of thought any human
being can fall back to any time so
that's a good question
so the phenomenology is not meant in its
early parts to be a history of human
development as a matter of fact the
early parts are much more abstract and
it gets more concrete and more
historically grounded as you're going
through it Hegel talks in the religion
section which is the second to last
section about there being these four
threads that are all knotted together
consciousness self consciousness reason
and spirit and you notice that the
reason and spirit sections are way way
longer than the other sections there's a
lot more going on in them and it's a lot
more complex a lot of people want to say
you know III want to you know like just
do the master-slave dialectic and I just
wanted to send certainty well Hegel does
wouldn't want you to like stick with
that he's not saying that the
master-slave dialectic is at the bottom
of every single society although these
dynamics what is good about Hegel is
that these dynamics do show up over and
over again in individuals and in social
dynamics
we're also confronted with the problem
that clearly things didn't turn out the
way ankle seemed don't neatly wrap them
up either right so that's that's a
question I mean can you can you get much
out of Hegel without thinking that
there's some worlds
spirit that's marching along and doing
the thing I think you can but I'm not a
Hegelian you know I just I just comment
on on Hegel and and teach him the way I
teach anything else I'm not an eejit but
I teach Nietzsche fairly - all right
academia dough is free - what is your
opinion about the relationship and
usefulness of literature and the
development of our philosophical thought
hmm good question
literature can be incredibly useful and
and some some things can be worked out
not just Illustrated but worked out
philosophically and sometimes better
through literature than through straight
out philosophy I mean there are some
great fiction writers I mentioned Iris
Murdoch for example I really like her
stuff she was also a philosopher right
philip k dick another great thinker who
really studied a lot of philosophy and
then brought it into his novels and he
has this character is thinking about it
talking about it responding to it or hey
said mentioned you know there's a lot of
really cool stuff that you could do with
literature that a philosophical treatise
by itself can't do and you can also
consider philosophical treatises a kind
of literature I think about dick Hurtz
meditations is it supposed to be just
like sat there and and gone through in
an analytic way in a classroom or are
you supposed to take it by yourself and
do the sort of thing that Descartes
himself was having himself do as he was
you're supposedly having these
meditations you know sit in front of the
fire and maldis matters over and take
you know you know do a while and then
stop and then pick it up another day I
mean that's that's a new way of reading
it or Anselm's Proust loggia you know
imagine if you actually use that as I
have in the past for a way of doing
meditative prayer
rather than like looking for the
argument analyzing it and making sure
that you point out where Ansel got it
wrong you know all that sort of tense
stuff that people bring to it think it's
so worked up this argument cannot
possibly work for the existence of God
you know and some is like hey you don't
like it if it doesn't convince you
that's okay works for me you know might
work for my fellow monks so I'm not I'm
not trying to convince anybody I'm just
trying to offer something that people
would enjoy so you know in a way he's
saying there's a aesthetic or literary
point to it I can't read that but of
Nietzsche's works which book today the
philosophers think is most important
that's a tough one it depends on which
philosopher you talk to right I if I had
to pick only one Nietzsche's book I
would say a genealogy of morals but a
lot of people like not will to power
know beyond good and evil no birth of
tragedy no you know there's there's no
consensus on that I'd say let's see here
another one for Makati
academia Doha spirito what is the
importance of logic and its techniques
both in the development of the
philosophers thought and a philosophical
investigation per se it depends on what
you mean by logic if you mean logic in a
broad sense you need it you need to
understand how argument works you need
to be able to assess arguments if you
mean formal logic even a can even
analytic philosophers don't generally
just put stuff into you know formal
notation any fourth or they used to in
the 70s 80s 90s and say hey look at what
we did I mean it's good study formal
logic by itself is kind of like playing
math games but it's good for your brain
it's fun might help you in real-life
arguments it might not real-life
arguments are way more complex studying
rhetoric is probably a good thing to do
both Aristotle and Cicero you know
really insist
and how important it is for the
philosopher to be well grounded in the
study of rhetoric I agree with them on
that so alright Mike would what does
cert mean when he says that a pop tune
is being in that mere existence in his
novel nausea that I don't remember being
would be I suppose to have more than
merely just bare existence it conveys a
kind of subjectivity to itself right
it's it's a human artifact you could say
so but it's been a long time since I
read the novel down Mayer Fitch what are
your views in meta ethics and practical
reasons I think mad ethics is mostly BS
I think that the notion that there's
like you know descriptive or
prescriptive or blah blah blah whatever
it's going to be first-order ethics and
then meta ethics above it I think that's
that's an illusion right every single
meta ethics that I've seen anybody bring
out always winds up having some
substantive commitments and assumptions
and they the people who are doing it
always have some sort of program
emotivism is a great example
you know relativism is another great
example and every single substance had
some sense of ethics if you look at the
tradition it's already got some meta
ethical scope to it talking about what
the nature of ethics is how precise we
can be how to make sense of the moral
disagreement how the other people have
gotten things wrong I mean just read
John Stuart Mill's utility or you know
Kant's groundwork and then actual
metaphysics of morals or I mean go back
to Aristotle and see Aristotle actually
dissecting some of the the wrongheaded
positions of predecessors and people in
his own culture they're doing is here's
the thing you can't do ax without
implicitly doing that ethics and you
can't do meta X without doing ethics so
I actually thought about writing a piece
called against meta ethics some time but
it's a matter if I
time to write it so right made of clay
thoughts and and before Montel I'm not
sure who that is maybe is that the lady
who drowned she was a philosophy
professor she saved a drowning person
drowned herself if that's really the
case then she walked her walk right
Shock Doctrine how do you define
nationalism I don't I don't need to find
most things but I would say nationalism
probably signifies several different
things some of which are you know what's
called legitimate and some of which are
quite poisonous you know and we could
talk also descriptive terms about about
nationalism in terms of movements of
thought or stuff like that
you know there's a really interesting
book that I translated never published
the translation long ago by Maurice
Blondell called pop de monte de homeland
in humanity and he was writing about
nationalism at a time when nationalism
was very very very strong in France and
in other parts of Europe and about what
is legitimate in it and what is
illegitimate in it I think the notion
that we should place all of our eggs
intellectually community wise into the
basket of the nation is foolish I mean
the nation-state does not reward us and
the folk or the people is a very fickle
thing as well I don't think that that's
that's something we want to do 31
manhood hi what's the value of
philosophy today what do you think about
Richard Fineman statement about
philosophy I'm not sure which statement
you're referring to
I'm not a fan of Fineman he's one of
these people that I see a lot of people
referencing and the little bit that I've
actually read I've not been impressed by
I think he's one of these people who was
great in his field but probably should
have stuck to just his little area the
valley of philosophy today it really
depends on what you make of it
philosophy is a
very broad term isn't it philosophy can
help you actually figure out how screwed
up your life is and how to unscrew it up
if you're using it right can also be a
very dry boring academic discipline done
by a bunch of people who you know quite
frankly shouldn't have jobs and
everything in between so you know really
really quite depends all right
Jonah Oliver favorite philosopher I
don't have one I've had ones in the past
I don't know I have I have a whole
circle of people who I really like all
right
kunal opinions on Italian idealism Croce
Gentilly etc I haven't read them for
years
so I don't have anything important to
say about them Jay to Nick what's the
difference between principle and premise
principle would be something that you
you again from I suppose that you could
use over and over and over again a
premises part of an argument hire and
Mitchell where do you stand economically
socialist capitalist as if those are the
the main choices or we just have a
spectrum you know I think that you know
capitalism is is good when we actually
have it I think that much of what we
talk about is capitalism is actually
monopoly capitalism or crony capitalism
and I think that I'm perfectly happy
with seeing you know legislation
breaking that sort of stuff up oversight
I don't trust really anybody to get
things right you know I'm you could say
I'm sort of like an old-fashioned
conservative in that respect
you know I distrust the the enthusiasts
of the free-market as much as I distrust
the enthusiasts of the the state but you
got to go with something don't you
so I find myself these days being more
of a critic of the right than the left
in part because I think the the right is
getting things worse
getting things wrong you know in worse
ways but if you know if I need it I'll
swing to the other side right I mean I'm
a virtue ethicist I'm not gonna have a a
camp that I neatly fall into and nor
would anybody else who who's a you know
really genuine I mean just like this
other one do you side with globalism or
the populism
they're both [ __ ] you know I mean
this notion that like we've got these
two great forces struggling against each
other that's there's a problem with that
that mode of thinking you know it's so
abstract it's it's so willing to like
not pay any attention at so what's
what's actually happening no matter how
complex your conspiracy theory is you
know or or you know account or whatever
yeah let's see let's skip down a bit
because it's 1:21 all right
so Nicola on Nietzsche when he talks
about revaluation of virtues and values
is he thinking about all values like
justice courage those that are not
commented by him like temperance pity on
me well he talks about all three of
those temperance pity and envy you just
got to read around and his works and
you'll find them discussed yeah he's
he's talking about you know having a
different understanding of virtues the
revaluation of values the the only our
throne does virtus has to do with or the
trans trans valuation of values right
has to do with moving away from this
this original you know good versus bad
morality or good was self-assertive bad
was what was weak to a evil versus good
morality we're good is defined
negatively against what is what is not
evil and then you know arguably nature
wants us to move beyond that to
something something else we're not just
supposed to revert back to the the
you know warrior class or something like
that oh boy here's here's a good one
about Iron Maiden
what did I think about iron made in
keeping Yannick gears while bringing
Adrian Smith back do I like the three
guitarists lineup I do but I've only
seen them play in concert once here in
Milwaukee with that three guitarists
lineup and you know it was good it's
it's sort of a wall of sound approach
and I guess it you know there's three
guys soloing or doing the two guitar
thing maybe you know one of them's on
rhythm when two are doing the same thing
together in harmony
I don't know enough about about guitar
to say much about Jana cares but I do
have friends who are very very good at
guitar who don't really like the guy so
you know I don't I don't know what to
say about it I mean I know having read
Bruce Dickinson's autobiography that
they really did want to keep Yannick in
the band which i think is a nice thing
and if they can all get along together
why not I mean it can't hurt to have an
extra guitar playing you know you can
see Black Star riders doing the same
thing that's what Thin Lizzy goes by
these days when they're doing original
stuff so that they don't know Sully the
memory feel line OTT but uh yeah I mean
I think with it with a lot of these
these with our made and I I don't I
think they've done reliably good stuff
for a long time there's nothing like in
the last two decades of albums that
makes me really with a few exceptions
that makes me go holy crap they're
they're on fire this is really awesome
stuff they're doing good power metal you
know the the greatest stuff they did was
probably you know the first six albums
but you can say that about a lot of
bands you know some bands you know
consistently did some really great stuff
through their entire career alright let
me skip down a bit more
[Music]
let's see what else we got
oh boy there's a lot of questions here
that I'm probably not gonna get to we
got five minutes left before I gotta get
to more work for the day the analysts
have you considered having a podcast
like discussion with guests fellow
youtuber Antonio wolf would be great
we'd love to hear you talk angles logic
yeah that's something I'll do but only
when I'm at a much higher rate of
patreon support because you know
everything takes time and time is is
exchange time for money all right how I
live I already do a lot of stuff as it
is and if I want to do more I have to be
a bit more independent you could say and
you know so that'll be that would have
to be down the line right now I'm
struggling just to get all of my five
classes taught that's more than full
time service all my clients that I've
got four for tutoring consulting
philosophical counseling make good on my
editorial commitments produce all the
videos you know try to produce the
Sandler's lectures podcast so you know I
would like to do other stuff down the
line but that's gonna take a while to be
able to do that let's see to do there's
a good question from from Zachary sort
of a nuts and bolts one can you pursue a
master's degree in philosophy without
having a bachelor's in philosophy
Bachelor and all the other subject like
software engineering with a minor in
philosophy you can at some places they
may make you take some remedial courses
and remedial means like you know
400-level stuff where it would be like
undergraduate and
students could take it together because
they're gonna want you to have you know
certain things down we had some people
like that in our program at Southern
Illinois University like they had a
literature degree or something like that
so that's something where you want to
write them you know get in touch with
somebody and ask them about that
directly ah step at a time here's a good
another good question I'm reading a fine
fellow I find reading philosophical
texts hard is watching videos enough for
my understanding of concepts I would say
no but it depends on what you're looking
for in terms of understanding you know
if your goal is just to have something
that you could think about and maybe
talk with you know some friends about it
could be enough but it you really do
want the text as a reference point I
mean even with so my videos I stick
pretty close to the text but how do you
know I'm not I'm not off how do I know
I'm not offering for that matter the
proof is you actually go to the text and
you say no I think this is this is more
or less on point or I think this is this
is not really on track so I think you
know you do want to you do want to read
the text at least make a try at it you
know and the more that you do the the
better you're going to get at it often
times it's difficult to to read
philosophical texts because they're at a
high level of abstraction and they're
throwing a lot of stuff at you know
oftentimes they're presuming you've
understood this this and this but if you
do it if you if you know you'll
eventually acquire sort of a map of
where they're going all right let me see
what else there is an interesting one
Arvid mom you said in a previous video
Marx's not influenced by sterner doesn't
the fact that Marx spent hundreds of
pages of sterner and that German
ideology point towards that no because
that's not what it means to be
influenced influenced means you like
actually take the ideas and you make
them part of your own thing reacting
against somebody is
the same thing as being influenced by
them so no all right what else have we
got here that's easy to jump in on oh
here's a good one
to go out on the scapegoat mechanism our
thought or what are my thoughts and the
works of Miguel de Unamuno I like
reading Unamuno he he's somebody who I
got introduced to as an undergraduate
because I was fortunate enough to have a
Spanish guy in the philosophy program
who also was a fan of
unamuno who would like not stop talking
so so I eventually had to read him and I
thought this is actually pretty cool
stuff I mean he like he reads a lot of
the same people that I like to read and
he talks about them like st. Paschal you
know and he really is somebody who fits
within the existentialist pantheon and
so I think he's you know well worth
reading like you know left chest off
he's not much read I think people
sometimes have heard about it more but
very few people actually do read him and
then Dave Donati I wonder what your
thoughts are on Dewey pursed James
classical American philosophy well you
know the place I went to Southern
Illinois University for my graduate
studies I actually worked at the Center
for Dewey studies for a semester and I
got Dewey like shoved down my throat all
the time by the do he ends I'm not a big
fan of Dewey I do really like James and
I do really like purse and more than
either of them I really like Royce and I
also like Santayana Dewey not such a big
fan but you know I recognize that
there's something there there is a
classical American philosophical
tradition and I think that it should be
celebrated as much as we celebrate
analytic philosophy or continental
philosophy or history of
speak but it's often overlooked
unfortunately you know analytic
philosophy colonized the United States
effectively and colonized it in the way
that like you know a fungus does where
it drives everything else out for a long
time now we're in a different phase this
post analytic phase right but it's it's
too bad because I think everybody should
read James I think everybody should
reread Perse but you know
odds are you're probably not going to
get introduced to them unless you're
like taking a class on American
philosophy are taking a class in
American Studies or semiotic s-- if
you're if you're doing purse so all
right well there are a lot of questions
here that I didn't get to as usual I'm
not they pile up quicker than I can
actually answer them let me see if we
can find something to to go out on
here's a nice thing from from Ken
Roberts hope you feel back to a hundred
that's very nice I'd like to feel back
to a hundred it's been a long time since
I have I'd be happy just to get to you
know reliable 80 here's here's a good
thing for two from from Kyle Howie
would I be willing to come to a speech
at an art school in London willing to
come to speeches anywhere
the trouble is people always have to you
know pay for the travel and so
oftentimes the the ideas about
invitations
they don't solidify once people start
looking at what airline tickets cost and
things like that yeah perfectly willing
to do that as a matter of fact I teach
at the the Maine Art Institute here in
Milwaukee Milwaukee Institute of Art
Design so I'm sure I'd have something
interesting to say although I'd be
probably a little bit out of my element
if there's any other nice things
ah yeah again have I thought about
having guests for discussion in my
videos I've done that in the past and
you know I do these interview videos
kind of ideas that matter these
conversation videos so there's a whole
playlist for those sorts of things all
right so I got to get going I got to get
to doing some grading and some other
work before I have my philosophy chat
with patreon supporters so good
questions I always enjoy this sort of
thing and hopefully I'll see you in some
other online event or in another one of
these AMA s so have a great day